well that's bringing some breaking news
this lunch time and polio has been
detected in sewage samples collected
from a treatment works in east london
our health correspondent ashish joshi is
here oh she said this sounds really
serious
is it is it just something that's
restricted to people in that area it's
potentially very serious and that's why
the uk hsa has declared a national
incidence because it wants to raise
awareness of exactly what it has found
and the potential impact it could have
on unvaccinated people polio hasn't been
found in this country since 1984 it's
largely been eradicated across the world
through a very efficient
immunization program but it still exists
in a few countries namely afghanistan
nigeria and pakistan
what is likely to have happened is
somebody who has traveled to one of
these countries has
come back who's been vaccinated against
polio has come back
and
that vaccine
has become um present in in their feces
or and and somehow has mutated and
infected other people i i have to stress
normally you would expect the uk
surveillance
of sewage etc to pick up one of two or
three cases of this every year it's not
uncommon what is uncommon this time is
that they have detected the same virus
over several months which
leads
health officials to believe that there
is some sort of ongoing community
transmission but between probably very
closely related households so so that's
the concern at the moment that it
spreads outside of that they are trying
to establish the extent of this
community transmission the sewage works
where they carried out these tests
that's in beckton that has a catchment
area of around four million people so at
the moment it doesn't present a major
threat but certainly immunization rates
in that part of london are lower than
the national average that is why this is
a public health awareness exercise to
try and get people to understand what
polio is how it spreads and if your
child has not been vaccinated to try and
look for vaccination
for protection let me read to you what
dr vanessa celiba the consultant
epidemiologist at the uk health security
agency said she said vaccine-derived
polio virus is rare and the risk to the
public overall is extremely low
vaccine-derived polio virus has the
potential to spread particularly in
communities where vaccine uptake is
lower on rare occasions it can cause
paralysis in people who are not fully
vaccinated so if you or your child are
not up to date with your polio
vaccinations it's important you contact
your gp to catch up or if unsure check
your red book most of the uk population
she goes on to say will be protected
from vaccination in childhood but in
some communities with low vaccine
coverage individuals may remain at risk
and and those communities in that part
of london do have a lower vaccination
uptake than the rest of the country so
this is a public health exercise just
make people aware that these samples
have been found and there is a danger of
community transmission